[Music]
witness some
we're gonna take our music for minor to
major league
[Music]
chose the night turns black this ain't
no fairy tale I won't quit and to see
what I could be
impossible with just a little courage
you could really be something
I got coverage let's take a trip back
back in the time
1977 it was maximum profit no natural
worst men working for drug dealers you
have a thought acquitted they sang
Disneyland this is the bra but it seemed
like nothing for me but trouble I see
the light it's right there at the end of
the tunnel
don't push me to be who you want me to
beat it nobody's asking what I wanna be
show me what you got
you truly are as fine as wine and so
divine you know I had to make money
I just want to sing I'd only get out of
the dance
I'm kids let anybody distract me from
that no daughter of mine is going to
disco
the way I see it all of us here on this
planet you're on a journey and it is a
mystery
[Music]
it's about music man it'll move forward
and open up doors and everyone says I
shut but if you do the whole work for
free if you just hold back nothing oh
you hear that that is life and destiny
that is the get down
[Applause]
[Music]
like the most
you